with only 24 hours to try and reel this
place in I need to find out what they
were doing wrong
so my team told the restaurant that they
were trying out for a traditional
renovation show whilst they have been
interviewed we installed hidden cameras
throughout the restaurant and have been
secretly recording surveillance footage
ever since we left
now as you know when people know I'm
coming to town they all turn on the
Southern Charm so I'm going undercover
Larry the luggage guy let's go and eat
some catfish gentlemen
good morning code name Larry so first is
Ryan Ryan Rob Rob JJ JJ good to see you
ready yes okay
let's go
here we go
catfish coming established in 1971.
looks like it was closed in 1971 gents
let's do this
hey how are you doing today okay
this used to be like one of my favorite
spots you know what happened I sang
Three ants drag and a hush puppy across
the ground no hey yeah that one okay
today we're ordering classic Memphis
comfort food the kind that made the
cabin famous let me do uh the hamburger
steak french fries as well fried shrimp
and your deep fried corn can I give a
catfish Shrimp Basket all right
I've got a hamburger steak cooked medium
[Music]
fingers
and more and grease puppies oh these
puppies that's right
[Music]
I don't know he might smoosh it down or
something
I get them out
of hamburger steak medium
fish and shrimp you had macaroni
the fish looks terrible
because she's all sunny and Limp a tad
slimy
oh
oh my God is it even doing no I feel
like it's been dipped in dishwater what
is that hamburger hamburger I mean
seriously how disgusting does yours look
um
it is bad
it's undercooked it's raw in the middle
oh man enough don't eat anymore gents
I'm done
ladies and gentlemen
all of you stop eating
Forks down
Madam can you give me the kitchen out
oh boy yeah we need it on the floor he
told me to come get y'all and bring
y'all to the front you for real yeah
come on
come on let's go see what this is
Charles
Madam just come through
is this Chef Ramsay oh
oh
[Music]
first of all I've just sat here for the
last 60 minutes with my guess and I've
eaten some of the worst food
I've ever tasted
what an insult to Memphis the Catfish
Cabin is closed immediately
now as you know when people know I'm
coming they'll tend to be on their best
behavior
[Music]
so I'm going undercover that's massive
Crema Jean ready for lunch
hello hello
[Music]
happy Birthday gorgeous thank you I love
you look you ready for lunch
my teeth are in
and we are ready to go go baby okay you
get your license
oh dude
[Music]
I should have brought my handicap
sticker here you go
do you drive at home uh I don't
where's your manners
she doesn't have any hello
good thank you
oh what smells in here
you smell it yeah
oh I know let's get out
ladies can you smell that what is that
smell I have no idea it smells like
something is off it's a swirl hello
everybody how are you welcome to Soto to
see if Peter can cook as well as he
claims we're ordering some classic fine
dining dishes
and he
Jean would like
absolutely that's one of my favorites
thank you so much you're welcome
you said hey
let's rock Hassan
mushroom salmon Sesame tuna well
oh only if there's a merciful god
if it wasn't that view outside there'd
be nobody here no nobody here we are I
have the song
that salmon yeah
yeah oh my God it's dry
sorry sorry I might taste a little bit
dark as well please
rubbery and dry
oh my God hi everybody how's everything
everything cooked
I like it okay
there's a sour taste for that Lobster
foreign
[Music]
listen I gotta get out of here
have I got a have I got a wedgie
[Laughter]
she is hysterical
food is shocking the smell is terrible
those ladies all agreed that they could
cook better food
[Music]
coming they tend to sing a different
tune so I'm going undercover
that is a beauty
[Music]
softball Steve let's see if this family
can step up to the plate
Slickers you ready for some interesting
food
absolutely ready yes I'll drive
[Music]
until you guys drive on the opposite
side and UK we do no there's your
steering wheel over here it is oh cool
yeah so I get home [__] it I just sit in
the middle
let's do it Gents
all the windows are tinted so you've got
no idea what it is inside and that's a
good thing because no one would step
foot in here if they could see the
poorly imitated Mardi Gras Decor how you
fellas doing did you want to start
trying our appetizers Cajun Hush Puppies
watering some Creole Staples bad gumbo
we should be a walk-off home run for any
decent Cajun restaurant black and
catfish under the trip I'd like the
Crawfish bread but after what we've
already seen I'm expecting this meal to
be a swing and Miss I think that'll do
it thank you man
who does go to it's the last ticket that
came in I'm not sure y'all hopping
around on tickets I can't do that
[Music]
as soon as it's time I thought we'd have
an appetizer right now hush puppy where
are you at it I think it is they
probably code at this point all right
got some hush puppies all right
so it smells like the oil in the fryer
hasn't been changed for weeks that's
smell
yeah that's not good
Miss Norma you know you got a gumbo and
a jambalaya no I do not it's on the
ticket with the black and catfish yeah
because I need to pay attention more
this happens way too often okay this
probably needs to go out
[Music]
I do have the gumbo right here yeah that
was me jambalaya crawfish bread and a
black and catfish
look at my catfish holy Moses
it looks more like salsa I don't know
there's something rubbery in it it
tastes like it's turned
oh my God
fish bread you're not kidding me it
looks like vomit on a plate that's not
how they do crawfish toast in New
Orleans trust me get your tickets out
first and then drop chicken don't do
that shut up and keep talking to me
crazy for real numbers
oh
because he's stepping up on me what was
going on in there don't step up on me
though
cause I'm about to step up that's fine
for real oh God
so question would you bring your wives
and girlfriends here after this
experience
no absolutely not no I guess unless I
wanted a divorce
I agree